other than that I really don't have any
friends
we have us and we will never I know I
will never let you down
will you have never Soviet eyes baby I
[ __ ] feed you i bathed you i wipe
your ass practically well I mean you let
me down the other day why cuz I wanted I
didn't want you to play video games on a
Tuesday no um I'll tell the story I
wasn't gonna do it so I go hey me and um
I'm gonna run go be downstairs okay yeah
so I what I what happens I go down to
the garage and you know I live in a
condominium so there's a garage for
everybody and so I close the door and I
realize that I don't have any keys or
cell phone on me so I go you know what
I'll just run him York Lila will come
down so I run Koby for about 30 minutes
with this tennis ball we go back and
forth
I give him treats and then I couldn't
open the door we were down there for
hours it was drama you're so drama two
hours it was 45 minutes that's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and mind you it was a
boom it was a 4:00 in the morning so I
was kind of dozing off and I realized I
said you know what yeah he hasn't been
back in a while so I was putting my
flip-flops on and I was on my way down
and sure enough he you know barges
through the door and he's like where the
[ __ ] were you like I was supposed to
know that he didn't have keys or a cell
phone so what I was doing is you know I
was like MacGyver down there I go I
gotta figure this out so what I was
gonna do is I was gonna go outside right
so I pried the door open to go outside
cuz it's this whole every door is locked
to get into the building and then I was
gonna hop up her fence and I had a
[ __ ] ID pennies I was gonna throw out
the window but then I'm like where do I
put go because I didn't have a leash as
my dog right so I put her and put him in
the dumpster but then I thought I
thought so I'm gonna go be in the
dumpster you know I know it's think to
myself I literally first what second I
want if Carla knows that I put the dog
stop story that she would get really
I just had a feeling that you would get
in here so I take her open him out of
the dumpster and I go I'm gonna cut the
way down here
I would've was coming to your rescue
yeah and then so then the gay dude next
door the gay Asian dude next door the
one that we previously had beef with no
longer squashed squash because hey
what's going on and you think it's like
I brought the dog in and I yelled at
kalila but that's not you being there
for me that's you being that's rude and
having no sense of time in fact that was
the opposite of the rifle that was you
not being there for you you walked down
there with no keys no cell phone at 4:30
in the morning that's your bed my dad's
gonna die stop saying that
don't say it like that no I just it's
coming I feel it you guys know yeah we
are you going to Phoenix again oh yeah I
don't know I you know I you know I don't
know how I'm gonna I don't know what's
going on but I you know that's real and
I know this is a comedy podcast but [ __ ]
it my dad is is almost there
I believe today I talked to my brother
and my dad was in the background and he
go
my dad go my brother goes put he puts me
on speakerphone you know hi dad in this
woody plant he went oh he's just crying
just hearing my voice
no and when a man hears this his son's
voice to cry that's a man who him he
says to himself that this is the end
that was no that was a guttural and my
brothers like oh my god what the [ __ ]
you know what put me on speaker and stop
sending photos of that guy
Tyla kid buds so that's why my brother's
doing my brothers taking care of my
father and sending photos of people I
sucked off you know what's so this is
gonna sound god damn it's really [ __ ]
up yeah but when my dad was I guess on
his way out
in retrospect there were some really
really funny moments you told me what
that maybe laughs funny moment like my
dad was sort of losing it like he wasn't
asked lucid anymore and he has pain
medications he was taking like a heavy
dose of codeine so he was losing his
mind a little bit you know and he was he
was bedridden but he was at home and you
know my mom sister night took care of
him but I wasn't home I was in San Diego
and I received a phone call and my dad
was frightened on the phone he was my
darling my darling there's a tall dark
woman here and I think she's here to
kill me
she's here to kill me and like my heart
was racing but then all you all of a
sudden I hear in the background my
sister cry my puppets you would he would
it was sad then I felt bad for my sister
but like in retrospect that shit's
hilarious and was that other one you
told me as he one time he he took all he
had an attache case that he would travel
with everywhere he was able to kind of
unlock his attache case take his
passports shove it in his diaper and he
was like mother you are
take me to the Greek ambassador like he
was living a lie I don't know Miller
Yeller little [ __ ] is that I have no
idea and then he started you know his
first his mother tongue is French and he
all he wouldn't speak English anymore
and he would just look at us and speak
French but that's what you said that's
when you said that that was the end you
knew that and came for me when I was
like okay the end is near when he
started speaking French and he started
to refer to his dad he's he would say
dad Oh a lot and I was like oh he's
seeing or talking to people that aren't
even here anymore or who have passed so
I took that as okay
that then is neon I think three weeks
later he passed I'm gonna you know what
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm
gonna call it speakerphone my brother
right now
oh hell is it too late maybe 10:46 I'm
gonna no I'm gonna speaker for my
brother because of what you just said it
really just let me just do it
what does he still have a ring back time
there cool dude it's new it's an is new
and hip guys from Cricket Wireless is it
cricket we spoke on the phone
Steve you ain't about to be he's not
gonna pick up what he's doing no destiny
no he didn't bring the Xbox so sweet why
that song the song with the classic one
oh you don't get to choose maybe I was
leave a message
yeah hey Steve stuff's taking photos to
kalila and myself of kids I sucked off
number one and number two if dad starts
talking to his own down in Korean let me
know because that's the end
[Music]